it looks like a fun new novelty
dining experience but safety is at the
forefront of this new york cafe owner's
mind
we spread the plastic area we spray of
course we spray the table
we spray the chair and as you can see
there is two opening on those bubbles
one there
one there we let the bubble breath for a
few minutes
until we get the new set of costumes
while some u.s
states are adapting to life under
coronavirus restrictions
others are moving in the opposite
direction we
are today moving into what we
initially called phase three and what
that will mean for the restaurants is
that
there will not be limitations from
the state of florida florida's governor
has also banned fines against people who
refuse to wear masks
that even as the nation's death toll
surpassed 200 000 this week
the highest in the world and while the
number of new infections has decreased
since summer's spike
experts say they are still too high
we have to do it differently because
things are way out of hand
we have 50 000 people a
day being infected 40 to 50 000 people
we can still put this genie back in the
bottle states like wisconsin and utah
are the latest to experience huge spikes
in case numbers health experts warn that
the oncoming colder weather
and flu season could see the numbers
worsen if prevention measures are not
widely embraced
images that can't be forgotten
in march italian military trucks carried
dead bodies away to relieve an
overloaded cemetery in bergamo italians
were gripped by grief and fear
as the outbreak of the coronavirus
pandemic upheaved society
now a little normality has returned to
italian life
bars and restaurants are open the
mandatory temperature check
serving as a reminder to stay vigilant
other european countries including
france spain and the uk
are staring down a second wave of the
virus
but numbers here are staying relatively
low
the figures in italy have stabilized for
several weeks
we are averaging 1500 cases per day
compared to the rest of europe the
epidemic hit italy earlier
so italy was very aware of the problem
and immediately put in place a very
severe and strong containment plan
experts say this is why italy hasn't had
to impose
new restrictions being put in place in
other parts of europe
apart from the strictly policed lockdown
and the robust contact tracing
italians have willingly adopted mask
wearing
italian citizens have been very
respectful of all the rules
when i see on the news the images of
other european cities
i see many more people without marks
than in italy
but they don't have much of a choice
because they risk being hit with a hefty
400 euro fine
i just think that people obey the masks
here and i think the police enforce it
and that's important
it's not to say there won't be a rise in
cases
authorities say they are expecting one
but many here are hoping that the
current measures in place
will make the second wave more ripple
than tsunami
[Music]
andersebe forest is one of madagascar's
many
wildlife tourism destinations owing to
the coronavirus lockdown
and closure of the borders the lemurs
that live here have recently had
more alone time than they're used to
visitor numbers are gradually increasing
but with international flights still
suspended the usual foreign tourists are
being replaced by malagasy people
this family made a four hour drive from
the capital to come and see their
island's iconic creatures
during the lockdown i decided i really
wanted to get out of antananarivo when
it was over
to visit new places we've never seen
before
i'm really happy to see the lemurs
because they're not in captivity
we're seeing them in their natural
habitat it's so exciting to see them up
close
to see their way of life even the way
that they eat
madagascar's tourism workers welcome the
locals
but it's not enough they need the
footfall provided by international
flights
though these have not operated since
march 2020.
this hotel and landowner used to employ
around 100 people
the majority of them have now been
unemployed for more than three months
usually at this time of year it's high
season and we'd be 90
full however now the tourists are not
typical tourists but local visitors
and we're no more than 5 or 10 full
[Music]
the pandemic is also having a disastrous
impact on local nature
forest guide pascal has noticed a large
increase in deforestation
the like of which he hasn't seen in over
30 years
because of the lockdown many local
villagers have cut down the trees for
firewood because they can sell it
others make timber they're illegally
exploiting the forest to make money
and as the trees burn so does the
natural habitat of the lemurs
mammals that only exist naturally on
this island
this is a fragile ecosystem but it is
crucial for madagascar's tourism
industry
a sector that accounts for seven percent
of the island's economy
stagnation in a place where people would
normally be having fun
this is not how uva rick had imagined
things
his fare had only just opened when he
had to close it down again because
of a drastic increase in corona numbers
in the westphalian city of ham
we've put our heart and soul into this
weeks of work it's really tough it's
shocking
we haven't earned any money all year and
now we're having to write off potential
income
and all of this because of a single
wedding celebration
where more than 100 people were infected
with the coronavirus
as far as anyone can tell there hasn't
been a single instance anywhere of
numbers going up in any way around a
temporary leisure ground
nonetheless we're the first to feel the
full impact and it's frankly depressing
that we are the ones who always end up
paying the price
the closure of the fun fair was only one
of the measures ordered by mayor
thomas hunstager peterman in a bid to
get infection rates under control
he says he's now looking at how private
festivities can be better monitored
we're keeping 150 as the upper limit in
hand because we don't want anybody to
start canceling a wedding or a silver
wedding anniversary
but up to 25 people these occasions
don't have to be registered
from 25 to 50 there must be advance
notice so that we know what's happening
and where
and from 50 to 150 they are subject to
approval and will be taking a very close
look
many in ham are asking themselves how
the couple in question
could have been so unreasonable
it's really annoying it puts people's
well-being at risk
especially if it gets worse and the
numbers go up even more
it's just not necessary
if everybody had just stuck to the rules
all this wouldn't have happened
i'm really not at all happy when i think
about it
it's no good putting on a huge wedding
like this with maybe 300 people
and then a third get infected and they
are responsible for a whole town being
confronted with special regulations
so far not everybody who was infected
has been tracked down
the mayor is relying on volunteers who
trace possible victims
people like retired doctor peter roder
it really pushes you to your limits
especially for people working at the
local health offices
who are organizing this whole operation
it's a real pity that it's had to come
to this i personally believe it could
have been avoided
meanwhile fairground operator uvery is
now faced with the dismantling of his
fare
i just hope we can get back to life as
normal that we can take part in fun
fairs and other festivals as we always
have
and i hope we can help make people a
little bit happy
for now though fun is on hold
they've never seen anything like it
gravediggers and jakarta now work around
the clock
racing to dig up to 40 burial plots a
day
before the pandemic it was just 10.
it's a job that carries the risk of
contagion and offers a frontline view
of kovid's tragic toll
rapper we're not complaining about how
many bodies we bury every day
it was very unfortunate for those who
died
they died in vain because of others
who didn't comply with prevention
protocols
jakarta is now the epicenter of
indonesia's coronavirus outbreak
the city alone is seeing more than one
thousand new daily cases
more than double the average caseload
from early august
a surge that's prompted another lockdown
people are supposed to work study and
pray at home
for business owners it could spell ruin
we only just managed to survive the
first round of large-scale social
restrictions
and here comes another one for now i'm
just relieved
that we're barely surviving but it will
definitely cause an impact
on our income
a tough call for jakarta's governor to
reinstate restrictions
but he says it's necessary to help
hospitals cope
and keep people alive it's not enough
for us to say
we're doing good because three percent
fatality rate is considered good
compared to other places
we need to see zero death
but for now the grim task of burying the
dead
continues without a vaccine
staying apart is the only way to stop
the viruses spread
and slow down the loss of life here's a
look at other developments in the
coronavirus pandemic around the world
germany has confirmed the largest number
of new infections since
april with more than two and a half
thousand in the latest 24-hour period
japan's prime minister yoshihida suga
has told the united nations general
assembly
that his country is determined to host
the olympics next year
after the games were postponed due to
the the pandemic
an experimental vaccine being developed
by johnson and johnson is proving to
produce a strong immune response against
the virus
according to the latest results the
early to mid-stage trial is being backed
by the u.s government
you